just looking at the pounds and it is
it's ticking every second and it's it's
ticking lower actually maybe we can show
you a chart on the screen because it is
quite dramatic when the statement
happened it started to rise a little bit
and then just in the last kind of 10
minutes or so
well you can see we can see there now
I'll show you I mean well so this is
just this is literally just over the
course of of today okay so it's from
last night
um and this is the pound versus the
dollar but it's a similar kind of
picture against the Euro as well
um so relative kind of stability
overnight that was more or less where
the statement happened so you see that
point where it kind of picks up a little
bit and then perhaps as people are
digesting it it's down by about a full
Cent against the dollar in a matter of a
few seconds
so these kinds of lines when currencies
fall abruptly immediately in a kind of
vertical manner
that's the kind of thing that is quite
disturbing now we'll have to wait and
see what happens next where does that
line go next it could very easily start
to bounce back but that is a sign of
investors out there being worried about
Sterling and that's basically a proxy
for saying them being worried about the
UK economy and pulling money out
currencies are very difficult to kind of
you know to predict or to rationalize
what's happening there so you know you
have to do a bit of approximation but
when you get lines that go down
vertically like that that's quite
unusual it's not a massive fall it's a
cent actually in the scheme of kind of
historical standards that's that's not
enormous but we're talking about second
by second here so you know we will keep
an eye on that uh another thing worth
with noticing Sophie
um the the guilt yields I showed you
guilt yields kind of government
borrowing yields earlier they've also
ticked up I'll bring that chart in a
moment to you but they've also ticked up
which means that investors out there are
liable to charge us more money for
Lending us uh cash which is what we need
to do this this starts with a very
simple proposition which is the
government wants to borrow a lot of
money to finance tax cuts and also to do
the energy price guarantee we need to
borrow that money somewhere and that
means International markets you know
that is the nature of the way the global
economy Works especially in your if
you're in the current country with a
current account deficit so you basically
do inherently rely on on International
capital
so this is not trivial that's really
important and the fact that the pounds
fall in there you know what we did what
I just showed you that's down to the
lowest level again since 1985.